dès lundi la rectrice de l'académie de
versailles s'est rendu dans une école de
vélizy villacoublay pour expliquer les
premières grandes lignes du nouveau
protocole sanitaire allégée en vue d'une
réouverture des écoles et collèges total
le 22 juin le protocole sanitaire va
être allégé à partir du 22 juin cela
signifie que au lieu d'avoir au moins un
mètre entre chaque bureau il y aura un
mètre entre chaque élève dans cette
école primaire environ la moitié des
élèves a pu retrouver les salles de
classe au grand bonheur des enfants
je suis contente parce que ça faisait
deux mois et du coup on a pu retrouver
les amis retrouver l'école et la
maîtresse du power mais alors tous les
élèves pourront ils ferment reprendre le
22 juin c'est l'inquiétude des parents
d'élèves pour qui le protocole sanitaire
annoncées restent trop strictes pour les
écoles primaires et les collèges
la distanciation physique ayant été
totalement levées en maternelle une
classe fait à peu près en tout cas sur
lui en course a fait en élémentaire ça
fait cinquante mètres carrés 50 mètres
carrés il faut mettre les élèves
remettent l'enseignant faut mettre les
tables pour m ils ont tous des armoires
dans les classes donc on ne peut pas
enlever les armoires il faut laisser un
sens de circulation dans la classe donc
on va pas beaucoup augmenté le nombre
d'enfants en fait c'est le souci qui va
avoir
bah oui peut-être de 15 on va passer à
17 ou 20 mais ce sont les classes de 29
on ne pourra jamais prendre tout le
monde et il ya beaucoup classes de 29 et
ça existe et c'est le problème c'est que
tout le monde ne pourra pas reprendre
côté enseignants on déplore le temps
trop long entre l' annonce du président
et la livraison d'un protocole claires
publiées mercredi dans la soirée qu'on
voudrait c'est pouvoir travailler
tranquillement et pour travailler
tranquillement il faut arrêter de mettre
des protocoles qui épuise les équipes
dans leur réalisation et qui empêche
l'accueil effectifs des élèves en plus
de l'allègement de la distanciation
physiques de 4 mètres carrés par
personne à un mètre des quarts
les enfants pourront accéder aux jeux
extérieurs et jouée par exemple au
ballon entre élèves d'une même classe et
les enseignants ne seront plus obligés
de porter un masque
sauf si la distance d'un mètre ne peut
être respectée
à